-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The tonight Show," everyone.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, let's get to some news.
Guys, President Biden
is wrapping up
his first trip to Asia
since taking office
after spending a few days
in South Korea and Japan.
So, if you're keeping track,
there's a drought out West,
inflation is still headed north,
Biden's in the Far East,
and his approval rating
is down south.
But Biden's trip is going well.
So far, he's only made one
statement that The White House
had to immediately walk back.
Biden spent the weekend
in South Korea,
and you could tell he really
started to pick up on
South Korean culture.
Watch this.
♪♪
-Smooth like butter.
Like a criminal under cover.
Gonna pop like trouble.
Breaking into your
heart like that.
-Yeah.
[ Cash register dings ]
Not bad.
He was just getting into it.
-Yeah.
-Of course, a big focus of
Biden's trip
to Asia is the threat of
North Korea.
And yesterday,
when a reporter asked Biden
if he had a message for
Kim Jong-un, he said,
"Hello. Period."
[ Laughter ]
That sounds like a grandpa
trying to send a voice text.
Like, "Hello. Period.
Happy birthday. Stop."
Yep, Biden said he's open to
meeting with Kim Jong-un
if Kim is "sincere and serious."
And Kim was like, "Oh, I think
I gave you the wrong idea.
I'm just looking to have
fun hookups this summer."
Yep, sincere and serious.
That sounds like a
"Fast and the Furious" spin-off
for your mom.
Meanwhile, North Korea could be
resuming nuclear tests
for the first time
in nearly five years.
But Biden said
he's not concerned.
Yep. That's how things are
going right now.
North Korea is launching a nuke,
and it's like eighth on
Biden's to-do list.
He's like, "Yeah, okay."
Yep, on his trip to Asia,
Biden has talked about
a wide range of issues.
And I thought he had some pretty
interesting things to say.
Here's Biden at a meeting.
Interesting. I just -- I don't
know what he's talk--
-Wow!
-It's just interesting.
Next, here he is at a dinner.
Listen to this.
I just...
It's just interesting,
what he says.
-Licorice soda.
-Wow.
-Here he is touring
a Samsung factory.
Listen to this.
It's just interesting.
Well, switching gears,
today, Starbucks
announced that after 15 years
in business,
they're closing down all 130
of their cafés in Russia
and leaving permanently.
That's a tough break
for Russians,
because they were just a month
away from their favorite
coffee release,
the Putin-spiced latte.
Yeah. Well, some business news.
I read that Applebee's
doesn't want its restaurants
taking pickup orders
over the phone anymore.
So it's setting up call centers
to do it for them.
Actually,
there's several restaurants
that use call centers,
and each one
has a very unique greeting
when you call.
For example,
here's the Applebee's greeting.
Yeah, pretty standard stuff.
Then here's Benihana's greeting.
-Wow!
-Next, here's the greeting from
Tommy Bahama.
-♪ Are you reelin'
in the years ♪
♪ Stowin' away the time ♪
-Yeah, it's pretty good.
And, finally, here's the
greeting for Chuck E. Cheese.
-Chuck E. Cheese.
-Yeah.
Interesting. Wow.
They're all different.
Well, get this.
I saw that Hot Pockets
is coming out with
a new thaw-and-eat sandwich.
So instead of using
the microwave,
you just take it
out of the freezer
and let it sit for a few hours.
Mmm!
Nothing more delicious than
a room-temperature pocket.
You can't win with Hot Pockets.
You either have to wait
three hours for them to cool off
or three hours
for them to heat up.
Oh, I heard --
Guys, check this out.
I heard that authorities
in the Midwest
are on the lookout for TikTokers
who have damaged property
while doing something called the
Kool-Aid Man Challenge.
Take a look at this.
-It's called the
Kool-Aid Man Challenge,
and it's recently gone viral
in Nebraska.
Teens are running
into fences, saying,
"Oh, yeah!"
like the Kool-Aid Man
and knocking the fence down.
-Yeah.
It's pretty serious.
So here now via satellite to
discuss the trend is
the guy who started it all,
Kool-Aid Man.
Kool-Aid Man, are you there?
-Oh, yeah!
-Alright.
Thank you for being here.
Do you use TikTok?
-Oh, yeah!
-And so you've seen
the Kool-Aid Man challenge.
-Oh, yeah.
-So you agree it's dangerous.
-Oh, yeah!
-Do you think the people
who have knocked down fences
should have to pay for them?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
Is that all you
have to say about it?
-Oh, yeah!
-I guess you have
to be careful of what you say,
in case anyone
decides to sue you.
-Oh, yeah!
-Yeah, alright.
Hey, real quick, before you go,
I always wanted to know this.
What kind of Kool-Aid
is in your pitcher?
-It's actually my blood, Jimmy.
I'm just a pitcher of blood.
But when you think about it,
aren't we all?
-Kool-Aid Man, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, did you guys
hear about this?
Jif peanut butter
is being recalled
for potential salmonella
contamination.
Yep, they're offering
two options.
You can either have salmonella
or chunky salmonella.
Hey, this is interesting.
I read that the average American
spends $314 every month
on impulse buys.
Yeah. I don't know.
That sounds kind of high,
don't you think, Higgins?
[ Whirring ]
-You know what?
People have got to be better
with the summer money out there.
-Yeah.
-Hold on a second. Wait.
-Yep.
[ Alarm chirps ]
-Had to unlock my Jet Ski.
-Yeah.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, Steve.
Guys, I saw that the producers
of "90 Day Fiancé"
are coming out with a new show
that will follow couples
who are trying to
run restaurants
while keeping their
relationships
from falling apart.
Yeah, the show
is going to be called
"Diners, Divorce and Dives."
Hey, well, get this.
According to a new survey,
new parents Google more than
2,000 baby questions
in their child's first year.
Yeah, Google
actually released some of
the most common baby questions
people search for.
Here are just a few.
First up, there's...
Next, there's...
After that, we have...
Next up is...
And then there's...
After that, we have...
Followed by...
And finally...
There you go.
Very...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Some local news.
I saw that New York City's
last remaining
public pay-phone booth
was just removed.
That headline again.
New York City has removed
its last public restroom.